ABCs of AI W is for watermarking
watermarking and generative AI are two
topics that are becoming increasingly
intertwined generative AI models are
capable of creating impressive and
realistic content including text and
images watermarking allows businesses to
embed a hidden identifier within their
AI generated content proving its origin
and ownership and letting the consumer
know that it is AI generated Google
cloud has partnered with Deep Mind to
launch a tool called synth
for watermarking and identifying AI
generated images this information along
with continuing advancements can be used
to avoid confusion protect intellectual
property combat plagiarism and ensure
proper attribution make sure to tune
back in for the last few episodes of